so
thank you for coming to our talk instead
of tom dales
it's gonna be awesome uh we also have
seven
talks to give instead of just one we
noticed a lot of really cool stuff
happening in javascript and the magic
internet land lately
and really couldn't figure out just one
thing to talk about so we copped out and
we're gonna talk about seven yeah so
like if you get bored just wait like
five minutes
so first we're going to talk about
education uh so i'm nick
i wanted to find a picture for us to all
get to know each other a little better
that's really great uh
and i was at the dentist recently so
these are my teeth um
my name is edward uh apparently this is
me i swear this is not photoshopped
the other guy is another guy i teach
with uh so we both work at shopify which
is a really cool
ecommerce and js and rails company right
and uh we decided that we wanted to do
more teaching
uh i've had a big big a big background
in
like rails development ruby stuff then i
did some developer advocacy
and then i went to toby the shopify ceo
and i was like hey i would really love
to do more
teaching and he's like no problem uh we
just struck a deal with these guys
called hacker you and they're like a
beginning
hacker school and we got
to use our lounge to teach the school
yeah so
this is about like 30-something students
not all of them here but this is a
picture of shopify's lounge the students
came from
across the world it was awesome in order
to do this thing
i needed a co-pilot so i like looped
nick
into this it was kind of voluntal that i
would be teaching
javascript and i kind of thought that it
would be like a one-day
javascript course it was not it was a
full-time
nine-week course where we just like info
dumped
everything we know about full stack web
development into these students
i did not find this out until about
three weeks into the program but it's
fantastic
um we decided to take a different
approach than a lot of other boot camps
we wanted to uh instead of like being a
super pressured stress
environment it was learn at your own
pace
you've got nine weeks and what's also
cool about this scenario is that
this room is full of like professional
shopify developers during the day
and designers and other people who work
at shopify so it meant that if you were
interested you could hang out and like
talk to people about what their lives
are like
you know like things beyond just the
technical portion
this really worked out for us yeah it
was an awesome program uh
and we learned a lot of really cool
stuff uh the first thing we learned
or the first thing we want to say is if
you're thinking about teaching
anything or even if you're not you
should just do it
everybody ends up learning something
from it it's not just the students it's
the people around the students it's the
teachers
and the people who are connected to the
students lives it's awesome
next slide um right we also discovered
that
the teachable moments happen in those
environments where you let them happen
just like
talking to somebody about how to do
something is not such a great way
to teach it's really like i'm going to
prepare
a space and a time and a comfortable
place for you
to like figure out which questions you
need to ask me and which questions you
need to ask yourself
in order to like index and unlock some
stuff in your own head
basically we started off the class by
basically giving the students a textbook
and saying here let's go through this
together and ask us questions when we
have them
i was like i learned from a textbook
this is the best way and then like 75
of the students were like this is [ __ ]
it did work for 25 percent of the
students
yeah but that's like the important
lesson is that everybody learns
differently
and what works for one student won't
work for four other students right and
like the whole like some people learn
visually
some people learn orally whatever uh
also
not really the case people switch modes
like ever at the same day yeah so we had
some
students who were like i don't
understand anything but the moment you
sit down with them and you like
draw a picture for them about like this
is what happens when a request comes in
and it goes through the stack
you like see lights turning on it's the
best possible feeling you can have
so whatever interaction may be whether
it's sitting down with them answering
questions drawing pictures
uh or building apps together like that's
when students are going to learn the
best right
so we decided to like not just do full
lectures this was something that we
figured out later on
we lectured for like five ten minutes
that we stopped class and then we held
little workshops for like 15 minutes
so again like if you were bored you just
had to
wait 10 minutes and then you would get
something totally different and during
these workshops
it's not just like one person working by
themselves we really encourage them
to pair program and talk to each other
and get better at like
the non-technical stuff like how do you
give feedback how do you take feedback
how do you work together on a team
exactly
that kind of stuff so while they were
working on their own uh basically that
gave
that freed us up to be able to walk
around answer questions help students
out with whatever they needed
but the problem that we ended up having
was uh our time was being too
uh monopolized by single questions uh
yeah there's only two of us
asking and answering questions from like
30 people
so instead one of our students decided
to make a solution to this problem like
this was his first rails app awesome he
learned how to build this in class
saw a problem in class that it was too
hard to uh
get questions answered so he built
hacker q get it
like hacker you but with the queue runs
so like okay yeah
right so um what was amazing about this
was this
was not something that we asked for this
is a student who was like this is a
problem in my own life
i'm gonna use the things that you just
taught me to build out a better solution
super cool this is what you want to have
happen when you're a teacher
it's really nice it uses web sockets so
people can submit questions pseudo
anonymously
we see them immediately can log in as
instructors or mentors
answer the questions students can answer
each other's questions that reduced our
workload as well
um but like have any of you ever taught
and done something like this like who
here
has a problem with what we're doing
right now is everybody comfortable
is this okay everyone understands it's
the worst
it is so crappy like basically you ask
that question do you guys understand
are we good can we keep going and all
you see is
yeah yeah like how many times have you
ever seen someone go like
yes i do actually have a problem uh
could you stop the class for a moment
and like tell me more
never happens everyone is like either
uncomfortable
they just say nothing or they nod their
head because they're like i don't want
to be that person that holds up the
class
so um i may have flipped out in one
class
and maybe called people some terrible
liars i don't feel good about it
but while i was apologizing to a large
group of people
some of them took it to heart and
decided to
fix that problem with the stuff that we
were teaching them so they built this
thing called curry
it has nothing to do with the fact that
one of the team members is indian that
stuff is delicious
so curry is short for curriculum and
basically what it allows
us as teachers to do is go through our
curriculum and our topics for the day
put in different learning objectives and
the different topics
and first of all this really helps the
students visualize and like get a mental
model
of everything that they're going to be
learning so we type this in they can see
it during the class they've got an idea
of where they are
and then whenever we're like hey does
anyone
feel uncomfortable like can we continue
do you understand
instead we just ask them to go to this
url and then
they anonymously hit one of these things
for where they are in the curriculum
and then we instantly get uh feedback
that looks like this
so this is another websockets app uh
it's a node server and a rails back end
and basically as a teacher we can see
this analytics view
and every time a student submits
feedback we
immediately get this bar and we can
gauge how well the students are doing
do we need to slow down speed up where
do we need to spend more time reviewing
so this was super super helpful for us
we did not ask for this
um super cool the students are actually
taking this
and turning it into a startup like tears
falling magic dreams this is exactly
what you want to happen
yeah students props to shop five for
letting us
teach the love of the web all right it's
very sweet okay next time thanks
um commerce.js we're doing neat stuff
with javascript at shopify which is
incidentally
a company that lets you open up a store
online exactly
so we want to talk about how javascript
is helping our merchants
uh sell more wares and make more monies
so i'm nick
uh these are my teeth this is edward i
look like this here there's tiger we
worked at shopify
we just launched shopify 2. so shopify 2
is a gigantic single page application
it's our merchant editing interface
uh but basically it's huge it has like
100 different models
thousands of different views and
probably trillions of lines of code
i'm not exaggerating uh no it's
definitely a huge app
and it's all built on top of batman.js
yo demo too many words
we're behind okay this is a quick demo
uh it looks like this
you can't see that oh no oh it looks
like this
yeah there we go why is it so little
anyway it looks like this so this is the
like admin side this is what
uh the merchant or the customer is
looking at and they can drive their
store
uh what's awesome about this is that
it's super fast there's
no page reloading you know the drill
it's all push state it's all
single page apps like shopify the core
side is instantly getting a lot smaller
like if you push yourself up on github
they identify it
uh based on its language so shopify is
now a javascript app according to github
because we've been taking so much out of
the rails side and then
producing this beautiful thing shopify
is just a rails api now
everything is golden and harmonious and
exactly how it was meant to be
so that is
shopify two oh my god all right uh
all right we made it an embedded app sdk
so at one point shopify makes this api
so that we can stop uh telling our
merchants no when they ask for
complicated stuff
because we're like go build it yourself
or hire somebody else to build it for
you
eventually that happens a lot and we're
like maybe we should offer
a place to market these apps so a
shopify app is really just
a website over here a web application
that happens to have
permission to access a shop's api that's
it so when you install an app it's like
i'm going to give permission to this
other web application the downside is
that okay right so this is the
back end of the shopify admin and
when i click on an app i get this screen
which is not like super intuitive for a
lot of our customer base
who uh weren't super like
self-identifying technical people
they got really confused by this like
they got over it eventually but they're
like
where did shopify go am i still in my
store like what's the deal
where have i gone so instead we're like
it should be like this instead
next it should be like this instead um
so this is a for real working
application um
the app is just like
this part here so there's uh like a tiny
iframe going on in here
but the beautiful thing about this is
that it can interact with the rest of
the shopify api
or admin rather um so it's an iframe but
it's using post message to communicate
back and forth
right so like inside of this app if
you're like can you pop up some stuff
that looks like you're in the admin
uh if you want to like show spinners um
all these other things modal style
windows this kind of stuff
so if you're not familiar with post
message it's a really cool
uh fairly recent dom api that allows you
to communicate between different domains
in different windows of the same app
securely so that's basically what we're
using to let third-party developers
uh run javascript within our storefronts
right so
why are we telling you this if you have
a platform
and you have an api you want to do
embedded apps
this is the pattern to go with we've
been playing with us for years
and run into all sorts of crappy ways
this is the best way forward
and we've open-sourced this as well uh
it's a brand new api
uh but developers are already making
like loads of money with it
if you'd like to play around with it
it's in github.com
shopify embedded app example uh
there's one more thing we want to talk
about with commerce uh edward have you
ever built anything that handles
discounts oh fancy you asked me nick
why yes i have it's uh pretty
complicated isn't it it is the worst
so like let's say i want a discount
engine that just gives you 20
off your order uh okay i can do that
okay but wait but only orders over a
hundred dollars
okay that's not that bad wait but it has
to be a hundred dollars before you
factor in shipping
all right okay but uh you can't have any
items that are on sale in your cart i
don't really know what you mean by like
on sale because okay that doesn't matter
but
you can only get a discount while the
moon is in a specific cycle you're like
a wiccan yes
okay exactly um no offense to wiccans
no that's totally cool so it turns out
it's like really hard to build these
discount engines
and yeah i don't really want to do this
like shopify does not let you do this
uh i don't think any ecommerce platform
would let you do something like this
we wanted to fix that so uh we're
working
on this prototype basically dsl
uh it's like a subset of javascript and
it lets merchants and developers
build their own discount engines
basically you get a blob of
json of the order before any discounts
were applied you do your like black
magic
exactly it doesn't matter what wicked
magic it is and then you
send back a uh json blob
of the order after discounts are applied
right and
shopify handles the rest yeah so we're
producing like prototypes that are
working
that are like little node sandboxes of
things
uh we're still not there yet but again
overarching theme here is
sometimes your customers love good dsl
and you should give that to them instead
of doing the work
um okay right so sorry talk three
uh quickly want to go through what's new
in batman js nick t
edward tiger shopify uh if you don't
know what batman is
batman is a javascript mvc framework
that we built at shopify with the
express purpose
of powering shopify 2. it's similar to
angular or ember
but where it differs is that it really
tries to
follow similar conventions to rails does
not mean it's rails only it's back on
agnostic and will work with anything
within ajax api
but if you are familiar with rails you
can start building apps really easily
uh so the main new thing that we've
released lately is the new site so we'd
like to demo really quickly
uh right this is one of the major
complaints about batman when we first
released it
was there are no docks please make it
easier for me to get started using
batman so we built this when you go to
batman js.org now there's a live
tutorial right in the site and it's a
live code editor with all the files that
you need
it walks you through getting started
building a batman app so if i add the
batman rails jam hit save now i have
some generators i can build a new
batman app right in my web browser oh
yeah launch that app launch app
so this is actually a running batman
application and it's basically like a
little windows
because i went to full screen mode oh
it's because you're in full screen yeah
there we go all right and now if i make
changes in this window
hey oh jsconf
and hit save then this window will
automatically reflect with
automatically update with all of your
changes so you can actually build a full
functioning
batman application in this little text
editor
and preview it over here the tutorial
walks you through building a whole audio
playlist management
application uh the other big thing that
we've been working on is docs so one of
the big complaints
was that our docs were insufficient or
out of date
so we spent a lot of time investing in
better documentation
and real style guides and uh
a lot more of the framework is
documented it's still work in progress
but we're you can use this now yeah it's
usable now so
foreign
just released a new version it's got
lots of cool stuff new test suite
coverage
batman rails is a ruby gem which is less
applicable here at jsconf but if you
have a rails application
lets you immediately get started using
batman with your rails api
uh and we're gonna start pushing this as
the best javascript framework for rails
developers
it was built for us at shopify which is
a rails application
and uh if you are familiar with rails
you're going to feel right at home
but you don't have to use it it doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to use
rails like
it's supported on node like you can
really have any back end
exactly all right so coming up uh more
docs clean up some more apis better
performance shopify is already really
fast but we want to make it even faster
nick when's the 10 coming
all this is going to lead to the 1.0
soon real soon now
all right donkey all right next talk uh
four
twelve two ones yeah okay teeth
so yeah here's some teeth i'm nick this
is edward hi
uh we worked shopify
so something i didn't realize uh until a
talk at jsconf us last this past js conf
by ray daly was javascript is becoming a
tool used for storytelling and reporting
it's being used in the media uh yeah
just today uh astrid gave a great talk
highlighting how javascript lets her
tell more interactive stories
it does a better job of eliciting
emotional responses
because through interaction the readers
and like the people who are getting into
this story can actually reach out and
touch things
they can get into it so here's an
example of uh the new york times's
snowfall article or story i don't know
what it's called now
so if you haven't seen this it's a
gorgeous article
about the avalanches in the washington
cascades videos
and all sorts of interactive stuff
pictures infographics like it's really
amazing
it gives you a lot more data and a lot
more background about the story
and what the reporter is trying to tell
you another example is
oh snap arcade fire just released this
new music video
uh yeah if you haven't played with this
yet do it it's amazing i'm not gonna do
it on conference wi-fi but basically
it uses webgl and your camera and yeah
your
phone or camera are like shining light
into parts of the screen
it's really cool so it tells you a story
it's a music video
it's amazing try it out it's really cool
play
oh god
play oh we're gonna die nope
come back okay there we go so snowfall
uh arcade fire
um this is really cool for a few reasons
um first uh that journalism has attained
a new
level of depth and a new method of
delivery that wasn't possible before
but also uh it's an indication that
javascript has become approachable
enough that it's now being used by
people
who again like wouldn't self-identify as
like a technological
person so a really smart javascript
programmer once told me
um that they don't actually like
javascript
or all of the compiled to javascript
languages not saying i agree with this
but the reason why
is because it's become too easy and it's
lowered the barrier to entry too much
that it's really easy to make really
dumb mistakes or
to spend too much of your time thinking
about other stuff
uh but a takeaway that i got from that
was it actually
lowers the barrier to entry uh it lets
lets us push javascript and technology
into places
like journalism and commerce where
technology would not normally be used
all right next uh talk quickly about
some
dsls and apis and why you should build
them in javascript
so i'm nick teeth edward tiger shopify
uh esls make
a lot of things more approachable
targeted a dsl is a domain specific
language uh it takes into account what
kinds of
words and meanings and subject matter
someone would use in their own domain
like let's say that
i'm a journalist or i'm a storyteller
i'm going to use
something that kind of looks like a
programming language but it doesn't
immediately make me think like oh i'm
playing with javascript or whatever
um and so when you build a dsl a new
developer
or somebody who's not even a developer
doesn't have to
learn think about javascript and the
browser and the dom and the computer and
all these different things
they only have to think about what your
dsl is actually providing like
the business logic they want to build a
good rule of thumb is that you shouldn't
have to write documentation
for a dsl because a new developer isn't
going to know how to read documentation
a good dsl
is approachable so what does a bad dsl
look like
does anyone know what this guy is
this is regular a regular expression for
parsing a valid email address and it's
probably wrong this isn't even it like
this goes on for like 50
000 more lines uh so regex
an approachable dsl maybe to some
probably not um we can do better uh so
here's an example of an okay dsl
this is actually uh from batman from the
shopify code base
uh i like this one obviously because i
made it
but basically it takes a lot of
different complex functionality from
batman models
and streamlines them into one consistent
syntax
and this model really clearly
like explains its behavior the common
dsl throughout batman
is a class an at symbol to say hey this
class should have this behavior
and then which api function you want to
call
okay here is a good dsl uh so
our friend daniel the other guy in the
tiger picture
um he's been playing around with
educational tools and products and he
made this dsl
for learning how to program
where's my chrome uh take us there there
we go
are we looking at the same thing yes
this is
uh except it's cut off really yeah
uh just don't full screen okay not full
screen
eight minutes
it's not full screen okay it hates us
that's good
drag that over perfect okay cool
the big takeaway here is that there is a
robot there are four functions in this
dsl
move down move right move left
uh whatever you hit run and the robot
does it
it's stupid simple it's designed to like
get kids
uh calling functions and getting used to
this idea
um it changes as you type it so
if you do this you'll start moving up
there's no like compile or anything you
just like
use this little baby dsl it's not even
really a dsl like it's just four
functions but
by streamlining all of it into these
four functions it's a lot easier for
kids to actually see what's happening
cool dsls uh they expose oh god
basically they don't have to be just for
apps uh or robots or discounts or batman
models
you can add a dsl to just about anything
right and suddenly you
expose another level of functionality to
people who
might not normally be able to add
functionality to your product and you
don't have to do anything you get this
all for free
uh i implore you to think about adding
some apis or dsls to your product
uh just like we do with the shopify api
all right like shoes
next politics js okay so
we worked shopify edward does not have a
tiger uh i'm nick these are my teeth
and my teeth and i would one day like to
run for public office
so let me tell you a quick story my
family got uh our first computer when
i was like six or seven years old and
i started uh programming because i
wanted to figure out how to hack these
awesome dos games
so i got some visual basic skills yeah
what dim everything game
everything uh i kept pushing and
learning with this magical thing called
the internet
eventually started doing some freelance
i got pretty into coco
and javascript and eventually this
framework called cappuccino
uh i then started university pretty
quickly figured out it was not for me
so i left went back to web development
and
got some pretty sweet jobs get to go to
some awesome conferences like this one
and hang out with all you wonderful
smart people my story
is not that special it probably sounds
familiar to a lot of you
as far as that story goes and
programming goes
i'm not the board the best i'm not the
worst so isn't that a perfect
qualification for running for public
office
uh it's something i'd like to do at some
point we can talk about reasons
why later or offline but what it means
that i spend a lot of time thinking
about politics and technology and how
they can work together
normally that evokes images of like
[ __ ] e-government and stuff like
that but it doesn't have to
thinking back to the earlier thing about
how javascript lowers the barrier to
entry
we can apply it not just to storytelling
and e-commerce but to politics as well
so one thing we could do is for example
uh start hosting
our legal code on github or some
github-like service imagine being able
to
access all of your laws in a format
uh in all the formats that github
provides being able to go back through
the commit history see who changed what
and when
actually right now like today there is a
legal hack fest
uh showing off this new api that the
canadian
association of lawyers have put together
so we're like hey we need to catch up
and offer apis and dsls to our own legal
code
so like that's being hacked on today
these are not just like pie in the sky
ideas this stuff is coming so this is
actually
kind of already been done uh united
states is
a i think somewhat parody github account
uh but one of the things he did is
wrote a scraper that scrapes the
u.s legal code and periodically updates
changes to github
so you can kind of go get the us code
from github it's just not
official uh
another one i recently had to go renew
my health card for ontario
and it took no less than three different
trips to city hall to actually get the
card
uh this guy named dominic heman
had a really similar experience with
germany's so-called e-government
you can read this article it's pretty
interesting basically he got access but
couldn't do anything with it right
the kicker is like none of these things
none of these forms
are so complex or so private that
uh you have to go through 20 different
people or 20 different
uh provincial employees so if we just
had a simple system of
online identity which we don't yet but
cool people are working on it hey
persona
yeah uh there's no reason that like
at least half of all the bureaucracy we
we as citizens deal with all the time
couldn't be moved online all right uh
basically
just keep pushing like keep building
cool stuff and
uh like build dsls
uh like chrissy was talking about
yesterday with persona ux testing
maybe name one of your personas after a
politician and think hey
could this politician use this
application uh and
if we keep pushing and we all keep doing
this then we can eventually get to like
a better more better place government
technology
harmony and that's something that i'm
interested in that'd be pretty rad
all right last talk uh oh [ __ ] okay the
sun never sets on the javascript empire
the javascript empire is growing yes
it's now available
in like hardware forms we're seeing it
in flying robots
hey um it's like i don't know if you
know this but like you can embed
javascript inside
a pdf and it will render properly you
can also use javascript to make a pdf
uh it's being used in operating systems
it's being used in
create operating systems yeah there's
another operating system called
jsos where it's just a whole os written
in javascript
but it's also being sneaky and not just
being used in different technologies
but different uh areas where technology
would not
normally be used or where javascript
would not normally be used so i don't
know if you saw this but the new sim
city
disastrous launch terrible uh fraught
with drm issues but whatever
uses javascript to do a lot of its own
like internal ui
and a lot of the rules engines and this
other stuff we used it uh to help
educate our students more better
different newspapers are using
javascript to make their articles more
interactive and add more depth yeah uh
we're letting
api developers do a better job and let
customers do our work for us
and like more and more politics and
government and technology
is being merged together and moving
online uh it's
javascript and technology are being used
in hospitals
in ipads in medicine in university as
admission processes basically javascript
is growing we've become a massive empire
and we can say
that the sun will never set on the
javascript empire
we agree with what brennan said last
night that it's going to keep growing
and be
the language that you write yourself and
going to keep growing and be a low-level
language
and it very well might end up being a
foundation for a lot of modern
civilization
uh we're we're all citizens of the
javascript empire
and we implore you to help it grow as
well
i'm gonna keep pushing it in technology
or in politics and government
yep i'm going to keep pushing for
javascript to go into education
and open data so maybe instead of
building that to-do app build something
that lets somebody else
solve their own problem build apps that
solve problems
outside of our industry get outside the
bubble
glory to the javascript empire and glory
to the uh
apps if he gets glory to the javascript
empire glory to us all
hey we're done